[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 más
de un millón de personas están sin
servicio de electricidad en Estados
Unidos debido a la tormenta invernal que
azota ese país 7000 vuelos han sido
cancelados recientemente el estado de
Nueva York decretó el estado de
emergencia
tres personas murieron y otras tres
resultaron heridas en un tiroteo
ocurrido en frente de un centro cultural
kurdo ubicado en el centro de París la
capital francesa las autoridades avanzan
en la investigación para esclarecer las
causas de este hecho
y la comunidad internacional
mostró su preocupación por el cambio en
la manera del registro de víctimas que
china adoptó para contabilizar los
fallecidos que deja la Nueva Ola de
contagio de Kobe 19 la más agresiva en
ese país desde que comenzó la pandemia
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 Gracias por estar
con nosotros hasta ahora vamos a
comenzar en Estados Unidos allí debido a
la tormenta invernal que afecta buena
parte del territorio del país las
autoridades indicaron que más de un
millón de personas se quedaron sin
servicio de Electricidad y más de 7000
vuelos ya tuvieron que ser cancelados el
estado de Nueva York declaró
recientemente el estado de emergencia
para poder hacer frente a la situación
el informe es de Rafael Pérez
una tormenta de nieve única en una
generación así calificó el National
Weather Service el fenómeno
meteorológico que potencialmente
afectará a más de 240 millones de la
población estadounidense las imágenes
satelitales muestran grandes masas de
aire sobre la Unión Americana alrededor
de 7.000 vuelos fueron cancelados
causando caos de Cara a la celebración
de Nochebuena
nos preocupa mucho que los vuelos se
retrasen o se cancelen afortunadamente
ese no es el caso hasta ahora pero he
estado ansiosa por traer a nuestra
familia aquí a tiempo tratando de ver a
la familia que no hemos visto en muchos
años debido al covid y las carreteras
tampoco son ajenas al problema los
conductores se enfrentan a una
visibilidad casi nula en la víspera al
presidente Joe biden advirtió de la
magnitud de La tempestad en una sesión
informativa
por favor tómense esta tormenta muy en
serio Yo no sé si sus jefes los dejarán
pero si todos tienen planes de viaje
váyanse ahora no es broma
más de 1,25 millones de personas se
quedaron sin electricidad igual de
afectada se vio la paquetería por correo
en este sentido la empresa FedEx afirmó
que habría retrasos en las entregas a
nivel nacional para el sábado se espera
mejoras en las condiciones
meteorológicas a medida que la masa de
aire se desplace hacia el este
y el congreso de Estados Unidos aprobó
el presupuesto para el año fiscal 2023
los fondos para gastar alcanzan los 1,7
billones de dólares dentro de los cuales
están 45 mil millones destinados para la
ayuda de Ucrania la cámara de
representantes dio su visto bueno a este
proyecto de ley por 225 votos a favor y
2001 en contra Ahora solo resta la firma
del presidente Joe biden para que el
presupuesto entre en vigor en ese país
en la ciudad de viña del mar en la costa
de chile las altas temperaturas del
verano han provocado incendios que han
arrasado con cerca de 7000 hectáreas
también con 200 viviendas y han dejado
hasta el momento dos personas fallecidas
las conflagraciones se mantienen activas
por lo que el gobierno decretó el estado
de catástrofe en esa zona del país
Andrés triviño tiene los detalles
las altas temperaturas en Chile generan
estragos los residentes de viña del mar
en la costa central del país limpian los
daños de un gran incendio mientras las
llamas se mantienen vivas y afectan a
cientos de personas y hogares el
gobierno central decretó el estado de
catástrofe en la zona ordenaron subir a
todo andaba buscando una amiga
desaparecía pero no la puedo encontrar
es un caos es un caos esto una ola de
calor que ha azotado a Chile con
temperaturas récord en algunas zonas y
la falta de lluvias ha intensificado los
incendios forestales que ya han quemado
más de 7000 hectáreas en menos de una
semana las autoridades calculan que
entre 200 y 500 casas estarían afectadas
por las llamas en Viña del Mar Por lo
cual han desplegado helicópteros y
aviones cisterna además de brigadas
terrestres
Bueno tengo tenemos Pérdida total O sea
la familia yo la tengo tan de mi papá
que está más abajo Así que vine a ver
perdimos todo todo se puede decir
documento perdimos vehículo lo que más
siento son unas perrita que se me
quedaron adentro así que están por ahí
están Están muertas afectadas a las
casas de mi suegra la casa de mis amigos
bueno se perdió todo
los bomberos han informado que las
condiciones climáticas actuales podrían
contribuir a que el incendio sea
controlado prontamente
Vamos hasta Europa tres personas
murieron y otras tres resultaron heridas
una de las cuales se encuentran estado
grave después de un tiroteo que se
produjo en el centro de París la capital
francesa los hechos ocurrieron en frente
de un centro cultural kurdo etnia a la
que pertenecen las víctimas las
autoridades de la capital francesa
investigan las causas de este hecho
la calle de John acordonada por la
policía ubicada en el distrito diez de
París alberga un centro comunitario
kurdo fue allí en pleno día donde un
individuo abrió fuego el restaurante y
la peluquería vecinos también kurdos
fueron atacados
vimos gente corriendo y luego entramos
en la peluquería y vimos que había tres
heridos en la peluquería entonces me
pidieron que llamara a los bomberos
el presunto autor de 69 años ya era
conocido por la policía en particular
por un ataque contra inmigrantes así lo
ha confirmado la fiscal de París en el
lugar de los hechos
se trata de personas que estaban
instaladas en tiendas de campaña y la
persona en cuestión atacó estas tiendas
se abrió una investigación a finales de
2021 y la persona en cuestión ha sido
puesta en libertad recientemente
herido sobre todo en la cara el
sospechoso fue trasladado al hospital en
estado de relativa urgencia acto seguido
fue detenido la brigada criminal se hizo
cargo de la investigación fue un acto
racista Las investigaciones tendrán que
decirlo una cosa es cierta Esta es una
de las líneas de la investigación
iracunda por el ataque la comunidad
kurda de París reaccionó
una de las víctimas asesinadas Hoy era
una de las responsables del movimiento
de mujeres kurdas en Francia Por eso hay
un carácter político Por eso hay un
carácter terrorista que nadie intente
hacernos creer que se trata de un simple
atentador orquestado por la extrema
derecha
el presidente Manuel macron reaccionó
ante el hecho calificando los de atrás
así también lo hizo la primera ministra
Elizabeth quien manifestó pleno apoyo a
las víctimas
china sigue haciendo frente a una Nueva
Ola de contagios de Kobe 19 que ha
llegado a los niveles que no eran vistos
desde el inicio de la pandemia
recientemente el gobierno chino fue
criticado a nivel internacional por
cambiar la manera de registro de las
estadísticas de los fallecidos por el
coronavirus una decisión que genera
preocupación en la comunidad médica
internacional
tiene causa preocupación por un rebrote
de covid unas semanas después de que el
país asiático levantara su estricta
política covid cero luego de casi tres
años se ha registrado una ola de casos
nuevos a pesar que se registran imágenes
como estas en la provincia de hebei
Hasta el momento las autoridades chinas
Solo han informado sobre dos muertes por
coronavirus en los últimos días Estados
Unidos ha pedido que se informe
realmente sobre lo que está sucediendo
es muy importante que todos los países
incluidos china se centran en vacunar a
las personas que las pruebas y los
tratamientos estén disponibles y más aún
que la información sobre lo que está
pasando se ha compartido con el mundo
la política cero eliminada el 7 de
diciembre de 2022 incluía largos
periodos de cuarentenas constantes
pruebas pcr y fuertes restricciones para
entrar y salir del país con el
levantamiento el gobierno también
anunció el cambio en Los criterios sobre
muertes de covid
Ahora solo aquellos que mueran
directamente por insuficiencia
respiratoria a causa del virus serán
contados dentro de las estadísticas del
covid la OMS expresó su preocupación y
pidió que se notifiquen todos los casos
a lo que china se defiende desde el
estallido de la epidemia china siempre
ha publicado información sobre la
epidemia de manera oportuna abierta y
transparente y ha mantenido actualizada
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
sobre la situación de la epidemia por su
parte Estados Unidos ha ofrecido ayudar
a China con vacunas y se espera que
Anthony blinquen viaje a Pekín a
principios de 2023
y para el cierre nos vamos hasta la
ciudad de roban ñemi en la región de
laponia en el norte de Finlandia Este es
el lugar donde reside Papá Noel y desde
donde comienza su viaje alrededor del
mundo Para repartir regalos con motivo
de las festividades de Navidad la ciudad
de roban yemi lleva a cabo diferentes
celebraciones tradicionales ante miles
de visitantes y locales que llegan hasta
esta ciudad ubicada en el Círculo Polar
Ártico para conmemorar esta celebración
con estas imágenes desde el norte de
laponia despedimos este informativo de
France 24 sigue con nosotros
[Música]